the Joe Rogan experience a new SEC
Alexander Rousseff yeah you know I'm
boring and I'm always watching pop
fights even if it seemed you know
Russian and Rip Trainer reading it
subtitles and he's one about Alexei he's
boring no I'm boring and just sit there
watching fights all the time it's just
why do but I'm there's a video of Lucic
and he was saying about now people
aren't moving the feet
he said you watched American styles and
the British they're all like doing this
and the Philly shale and stuff like that
they're not moving the feet anymore
which a famil is really interesting
because if you look that the footwork
he's there for what he's so superior a
lot of people in llama when he way for
Tony Bell you pop a great performance
against him but II just put him in a
position and the end of it he was [ __ ]
yeah not many people realized what he'd
actually done evil as well he'd put him
there and they were waiting I'm waiting
away and when he got him they knew
weaken gowing bang it would have been
amazing if we got a chance to see Floyd
versus Loma when I was in his prime yes
that would have been [ __ ] incredible
to see which style superior yeah Lloyd
would move towards you like this you
just get right up on you and they'll be
trying like me like I think you think it
was one that we use that he was talking
to someone where he was Mayweather floor
Pretty Boy Floyd and money Mayweather
it's like to dip is money Mayweather yes
the pretty body flight was better and he
was more on his feet sharper on his
right hands when he fought Philip and
doing it and would like six right hands
like what I did he got in stuff I was
that was a horrific there I remember
watching now only young as well when I
watched Iron Man figure [ __ ] LT right
being bad yeah and he was executing well
no desire I mean no business being in
the middle of him yeah but just show you
how good Floyd really is yes you know I
mean people just because the fact that
he's won decisions by you know playing
it safe people just don't get excited
about I'm gonna recognize him with the
all-time greats he's the best
lutely school they just absolutely
changed canal started it you look at the
way to nullified the Daniel Jacobs if
France
so much head movement and somewhat so
elusive now yeah he learned yeah you
know will you think about canal going up
and fighting kovalev I'm crazy you know
you know I'll be you know I don't think
I'm rubbish it for protecting fights I
am over agent that means he's not no I'm
really bad at predicting fights wearing
a bot we have a boxing group and what's
up the boxing team gets called and I
always get it wrong you guys use what's
out that is such a [ __ ] British thing
no one knows what the [ __ ] and I think I
think that the key for Kovalev is his
job I think the thing is everyone thinks
that he's easy to hit to the body but
Andre Ward was amazing and slipping
underneath that Jamie was so good at
that if he's just sticking him amongst
normal people but he was tested in his
last fight Anthony yard in round 8 you
were gone in round a yeah he's well to
recover from walking I mean it looked
bad like he was a couple punches away
yeah being stopped yeah saved by belly
but 20 more seconds he might have gone
I think it said getting him at the right
time do you think what cover life still
in it with his job he's better now we've
put him a girl because he'd be Alvarez
after that if they've got lost to
Alvarez only for Alvarez again he look
great and but against yard young hate
yabbies massive as well yeah didn't have
enough experience yeah that's really
what a team fights
18 knockouts yeah just whitefall of
everyone never mean it not deep war and
never being at world level and they put
in a good account of himself like but
like dangerous as [ __ ] after that fight
yes yes gonna want that experience and
understand like wow his conditioning is
probably a little off yet maybe needs to
lose a little bit of muscle mass yeah
needs to put in more running but god
damn he's good this is a very powerful
kid yeah
[Applause]